okay welcome back to the ads it's the
afternoon session which will be on
Lossless to pass it's an absurdity and
we're very happy that correctly is
finished thanks thanks for the
invitation and thanks for coming so the
organizers asked to talk about
connections between statistical learning
statistics optimization online learning
and so initially this talk was just the
horrendous compendium and and the couple
of people looked at it and said no no no
this is supposed to be a tutorial so
right now it's very low it's just about
35 slides for two hours very low on
content if I understood that I apologize
and if this is too easy I apologize if
it's too hard please ask if I say
something that you know the concept that
is not known please let me know so we'll
talk about mostly about learning and
definitely learning has been one of the
main consumers machine learning has been
one of the main consumers of
optimization in the last I guess five
ten years and and I will show a couple
of directions where I think a lot more
can be done by optimizers and both in
discrete and continuous optimization and
that's kind of an exciting ok so what
does this talk about very broadly we'll
talk about several ways to phrase
learning depending on how you phrase it
you get a different optimization method
will discuss some basics of online
prediction online learning methods and I
will make a few connections between
statistical learning and online learning
these are probably concepts that you
haven't seen and as well as the first
order optimization so again please stop
me if there is a concept that is unknown
okay actually I will start with a board
this is an example that I like to to
start with
suppose that you're trying to predict a
sequence of bits so the sequence y1 y2
comes in and the values are let's say in
0 1 and what do we what do you mean by
predicting at all you you you want at
every time step you output a prediction
let's say it's y had 1 up to you know Y
hat - and so forth and now you count the
number of correct predictions and let's
say see T bar is the average or the
ratio of fraction of correct predictions
fraction of correct predictions and let
me denote Y hat T by fraction of ones in
the sequence just the average of the of
the Y sequence okay up to time T
subscript up to time T ok so first
question is you know suppose that you
know that the sequence is Bernoulli
they're newly IID okay with some unknown
bias be and you're trying to do this
prediction what would you predict this
is a undergraduate question
majority majority of course you predict
the majority predict the so Y hat T is
an indicator of whether Y bar T is more
than one half okay and what what does
this give you well it gives you that the
the correct
you know the fraction of correct
predictions goes in some sense that you
can make precise to the maximum of P and
1 minus P of course right so the the
maximum of the how imbalance the
sequences and by the by the law of large
numbers it's going to be a y bar T and
one minus y bar team right so you can
replace the piece by the average more
precisely if you want to know the the
more precise statement so you can say
that limb in of CT bar - max of Y bar T
and one minus y bar T so this lymph is
not negative almost surely ok this is a
random sequence this is a almost sure
statement ok so that's the kind that's
the the notion in which this squiggly
arrow is pointing ok so look at the
proportion of correct predictions is
going to be roughly a proportion of Y
bar T and 1 minus or bite Y bar T ok so
the punchline now is that this statement
will be colored by a star
this trivial statement there exists an
algorithm a prediction algorithm that
attains star for any sequence y1 and so
forth
there is no generative process that is
required on the sequence it holds for
any sequence of course that's an almost
sure statement so it's clear that the
method itself has to be randomized right
in fact it's clear that the method has
to be randomized because for any method
you can come up with a sequence that
will break it right on every round for a
very deterministic method right any
deterministic method you just output the
Y output the bit that's opposite to what
it would predict right so that's that's
clear but this is a non-trivial
statement so I invite you to spend maybe
a fifteen seconds to try to think how to
do this how you would you would get such
a result and let me just make it even
simpler you know try to think of how one
would obtain a proportion of correct
predictions approximately you know max
for a finite let's say I I will give you
a finite horizon M can you come up with
a method that will attain maximum of y
bar and one minus y bar and plus you
know something that is a little of one
right so it goes down with M right
anyone has a suggestion
just corresponding to like I said
sprightly if you like look at the
distribution over currently seen values
would you like sample out from pardon I
distribution up return that spray
that would essentially go with the it's
a randomized strategy who's expected who
whose value is the the the mean so far
right so the mean so far is not gonna do
it
it has to be something else
oh yeah sorry yes I mean pick theory
equal to the fraction of so I think that
was that's what was suggested but I
think that will not do it you can come
up with a counter you can do but if you
know about experts you would do some
kind of experts algorithm that's one so
the solution another solution is given
by David Blackwell who was a faculty
here so it's nice to talk about this in
the statistics department so here's a
strategy you you write you know you draw
a zero one two zero one box on this axis
you plot y bar on this axis you plot C
bar right this is the center draw this
is like a flag and where do you want to
end up right you want to end up in this
region so if you know black will
approachability that's suggesting how
you should do it right why do you want
to be in this triangle because you want
to be above Y bar and one minus y bar
right so you want to be in this room so
the method is the following at this
current moment well if you were here
you're fine you don't have to do
anything right you're going to flip a
coin if you are here predict
deterministically I guess is zero if you
were here predict deterministically the
other bit and if you here in terms of
this so the current point is y VAR t c
bar t right these are the statistics
that you keep how many times you
correctly predicted them how many times
one appeared in the sequence right so
these are the only two statistics you
know you need to know about the sequence
if you're in this triangle you connect
this line projected on to this axis and
this is your mixed strategy completely
on none of this right this is a how do
you get this where does this come from
right and and this is roughly what this
talk is about and so that's what they
that's what they talked about them and
this is actually from the paper of David
Blackwell so how many of you know about
the Blackwell approachability and the
vector-valued payoffs the minimax
theorem okay only a couple of people
okay
so David Blackwell an amazing person you
know it's done really beautiful work in
various areas I think this is one of his
last papers and it talks about this
problem okay and and here's a quote from
him the contrast between the minimax
predictor that's the one for arbitrary
sequence and the base predictor that's
the this one right is strong the minimax
predictor is not obvious as we saw it
satisfies this star with for every
sequence right for him that's the
sequence but the proof is not easy the
base predictor that's just the you know
minimize the empirical loss you can view
it as a empirical minimizer is
completely obvious it's not randomized
and it satisfies this for almost all
sequences but under the stochastic model
right and the proof is simple so the
point that I'm trying to make is that
you know we can be lazy and we can
assume that the data iid and then it's
usually clear what to do you minimize
some kind of average empirical risk
minimization is there kind of the key
word here but it turns out that one can
get similar results by working harder
for arbitrary sequences and that's a
result that's much more appealing
because it does not rely on the iid
nature of
the model right hopefully the method is
more robust because it does not rely on
the iid nature when I say iid is a fear
everyone knows what I ideas right now
that's independent and identity and then
identically distributed okay it's about
this particular proof right and then
we'll see some examples where it's not
easy on the other hand I will give I
will show that it's a dynamic program
and there are there's no magic to it
right this seems like magic but there
isn't it we can take magic out of this
that's a very good question right so
what will actually start from
statistical learning where you do assume
that the data iid and then we'll move to
this individual sequence world slowly so
we have enough time okay right so the
model that I will consider or the
setting that I will consider is that we
don't don't just have bits but bits come
with some excess all right some side
information and that's the more
interesting situation where you have a
two poles that's the usual machine
learning or statistical setting you have
covariates something you know it's a
vector of what you know about let's say
the person and so forth and then why is
the response in this case it's going to
be either real real valued number or for
the most of the presentation it's just
going to be plus minus 1 right
so again bits but the bits are come with
some X's right dr. covariates and and we
hope we have a hope that a linear
function W times X is a good explanation
of why and the reason I did not make
this more formally is because there is
there are several ways of formalizing
this hope right so one can formalize
this in the form of a stochastic model
so y is equal to W times X plus noise
and that's what the statistician
or one can hope that that's the case by
trying to do as well as a benchmark
which is only small when this is in fact
correct right so that that's what's
called statistical or statistical
learning we'll make it we'll make it
formal but that's a roughly the the idea
this is the simplest thing you can
imagine right W times X so the way that
we hope that the Y is explained from X
is by a linear function but it already
captures quite a few interesting
scenarios one of them is this matrix
completion or the movie rating
prediction problem let me describe it to
you we observe N and is always going to
be the horizon or the the sample size
okay for us it's the same n as in this
question and what we observe is n movie
user pairs with the rating like or
dislike so let's say each XT is just the
identity of the user and the identity of
the movie this is the the zero zero one
vector
okay so XT here is actually a matrix and
I apologize I'm gonna be writing small
letters rather than capital letters from
matrix it's unusual but I will reserve
capital letters for random variables so
X is a matrix 0 1 is just the indicator
at the movie user allocation and Y is
whether the person liked the movie or
not right so you've given maybe a batch
of these data and you want to do
something or you given this as a
sequence right and and you hope and this
is a usual assumption or hope is that
there is a low rank matrix or maybe a
low trace norm low nuclear norm matrix W
that will explain the Y's from the X's
right that's the correspondence is that
clear
why this is a linear problem
much of what I'm gonna say carries over
to nonlinear problems this is just way
much much easier to talk about the
linear case and so I we haven't yet
specified what what what is learning
right and depending on how we set this
up that will define somehow the the
algorithm that we're gonna come up with
the optimization problem and and I want
to emphasize that learning is
out-of-sample performance right so
whatever the definition of learning we
come up with it should be out-of-sample
somehow right so you've seen some data
and now you have to make a prediction
out-of-sample right so just writing down
let's say you know fit to data plus some
penalty I it's not clear why this is
learning until you show that this
actually does what you want right in
terms of the out-of-sample performance
so a natural method to that people would
would think of is just fitting the data
right so given a class of vectors or
matrices find that explanation that that
best fits the data and here I'm going to
be using a absolute loss we can may we
can take instead the hinge loss the
hinge losses
los is defined as L of a B max of 0 and
1 minus a B so we could use that pretty
much nothing will change I am still
thinking of wise now as a as a plus
minus 1 variable so in fact you can just
say it's 1 minus y times the inner
product okay and and from now on I will
denote this objective as L hat hat from
now on will signify the dependence on
the data right so this is a data
dependent objective and so we will think
of this as an L hat of W as a function
of W any questions at this point
oh yeah sorry sorry yes yeah this is T
yes thank you
what is f so f is something I haven't
yet specified in the to make it
exposition simpler it will often be a
bowl so it's a vector that lives in in
some norm Bowl right with respect to
some norm I will make it more precise so
okay so some examples for the matrix
completion example it would be natural
to take to replace the rank constraint
so we were we're hoping that there is a
low rank explanation of Y from X again
this should be T's it makes sense to
take F to be a nuclear norm bolt so
remember that nuclear norm is is a sum
of singular values of the matrix and
sometimes perhaps it makes sense to cap
the prediction values W by 1 because
after all we're trying to predict a
number of like this like plus minus 1
right but sometimes I will drop this
when we want to look at the dual norm
ball and if we're thinking of the
original problem as a rank are matrices
then it makes sense to think of the this
bound tau as a square root of r times
the product of the dimensions of the
matrix to include those matrices right
so this is a relaxation of that set and
that's one example okay so a question
now is you know why is why is w hat good
in terms of prediction of future ratings
right and that's the question right so
we want to talk about learning but I
propose some optimization problem why is
the solution of this optimization
problem any good for for in terms of
future right so now we have to talk
about future right so how do you how do
you formalize the notion of a future and
one way to do it is through the setting
of statistical learning where you assume
that the data that you've seen in fact
are an iid sample from some unknown
distribution right and you're going to
be evaluated on another point X Y from
the same distribution right so if you
subscribe to statistical learning kind
of framework you have to believe that
out there there is a dis distribution
and what you've seen is a bunch of iid
sample you know
bunch of iid pairs from that
distribution the distribution is unknown
to us so that's important distribution
is unknown we don't want to assume that
we know the distribution again you can
pick a different loss function in fact
you could pick square to make it
regression it would just complicate the
analysis a bit more and so I want to
keep it as simple as possible so let's
stick with the absolute value as the
loss function right the loss function is
what compares the Y to the prediction
okay so if you think of matrix
completion this is a bit problematic
right the the the the the iid assumption
for matrix completion with the movie
example in mind that's a little bit
problematic right it's it's it's a
stretch of imagination that what we
observed was an iid you know user picks
a movie at red at random and then this
is a kind of inner some kind of iid
process it's a stretch right but let's
just stick with it and see how far we
can get and then we'll move to something
more interesting okay and so here's the
conundrum and of course you see if
you've seen this this is kind of trivial
the empirical risk minimization for so
from now on that w hat is the one that
minimizes L hat right I'm gonna call it
empirical risk minimizer it just fits
the data right so that's the empirical
risk minimizer the empirical risk
minimization minimizes this L hat
objective but what we want is we want to
minimize the L of W right L of W is the
out-of-sample performance on the new
data point XY pair right here and the
expectation is over this XY pair from
the same distribution is the setup clear
any questions
we're going too slow okay so so and the
situation is that the if you want the
picture
and we have a convex objective that we
want l of w okay I don't know what it
looks like L of W this this is the point
that we want right over W over you know
a set F this is the set F so that's the
point we want instead what we observe is
a random convex function might be I
don't know looks something like that
right and it's a random why is it random
because the data are random and so when
we come up with L hat that's a random
objective appear so our performance can
be only as good as the expected supremum
of the difference of the two objectives
okay of course this is an upper bound so
you can say well this can be loose but
for this particular example this is s
this is tight up to constants right so
what we what we can say is that the
expected objective that we want
evaluated at the empirical risk
minimization solution at the one that
fitted the data is going to be close to
the minimum the W star this is the black
point up to the the band that controls
the difference of these two functions in
expectation
I'm here I don't think you need an
absolute value so you can write it as L
of w hat minus L hat of w hat plus L hat
of w hat minus L of L hat of W star
which is negative plus L hat of W star
minus L of W star which in expectation
is 0 so I think you don't need that
absolutely you could it would only
change things up to a constant
generalization error right these are the
empirical quantities the empirical
average so w hat so let me write it down
so we don't we're not confused so w hat
is the minimizer of the so L hat of W is
1 over n sum of Y I minus W X I i from 1
to n that's in its empirical minimizer
right so the minimization of this is w
hat hat is arc min of L of L hat of W
please ask if some notation is done here
and W star is the optimal is the optimal
of the expected objective
so this this you can think of this as a
agnostic pack if you think of binary
prediction except I'm I'm using the
these as real values so there's not
indicator loss but the absolute loss for
just simplicity
so the point here is that if we could
get a handle on this band uniformly over
W then we're done for this example again
this is kind of the best you can do it's
a VC dimension is just one way of upper
bounding it and there is a better way
well potentially tighter way of doing so
if you haven't seen the step this is
called uniform convergence so any
statement of this form going to zero
this is this quantity depends on N and
so any statement of this form saying
that it goes to zero would would be a
statement about uniform convergence
right why is it uniform because you were
saying for any W in my set F these two
curves are two objectives are close
okay so how bad can this be how do we
analyze this okay good good so this is a
good plan so the question is what what
is this expectation what are the
different expectations over this
expectation is over XY pair that's the
out-of-sample performance on a new data
point okay
this expectation is over the data you
draw n data points and W hat is a random
variable in those data so you have to
take an expectation right you can make
this into a high probability statement
as well but this expectation is also
over the data
yes some boundedness of something so we
will have to yes yeah so next slide yeah
yeah yeah so if you let in this case if
you let W to be to go without bound like
f to be unbounded then just nothing
right but okay so let me introduce one
more concept and I think that's pretty
much the last kind of probably
unfamiliar concept to people so let me
spend a little bit of time on it it's a
concept of Rademacher averages in
particular empirical Rademacher averages
and so it has a quick calculation so I
can do this calculation if you would
like or I can just state the result so
you know people yell if they want to see
it
let me explain first what the what the
quantity what the quantities are the
statement is that the the expected
supremum that this band the width of the
band that we are trying to control can
be further upper bounded by twice
expected our hat of F our hat of F is
empirical Rademacher complexity let me
write it down
or empirical Rademacher averages I'm
going to denote it by our hat of F and
this is going to be expectation with
respect to epsilon 1 through epsilon n
epsilon 1 through reps on n for the rest
of the lectures our Rademacher random
variables these are plus minus 1 50/50
probability so coin flip plus minus 1
right expected supremum W in F of 1 over
n sum of epsilon T W X T C from 1 to n
X's do not have to be symmetric there is
no right so the term empirical refers to
the fact that we're thinking of X's is
fixed at this moment the only randomness
in this quantity is with respect to the
random coin flips
that's the only
this would yes the that's that's the one
thing yes yes so the question is the we
get to this quantity because indeed
because we chose absolute value as the
loss function if you chose a square loss
we would get a related quantity but
they're slightly different and there's a
lot of work on you know what is the
right quantity in there there's just for
simplicity
now maybe it looks scary so let me show
you that it's not scary at all for the
cases that we will consider at least so
take take f to be equal to X so that the
X variable will also come from the same
set as the F and that's going to be a
Euclidean ball and D dimensions D will
never appear so it can be infinite
dimensional if you want that's a union
ball if you know about the kind of the
dual pairs the reason why we put the
covariates in the same space as the
double use is because the this is the
Euclidean geometry and the dual of the
l2 ball is a l2 ball
ok so let's just think of rewriting this
this is a expectation epsilon 1 through
epsilon n of supremum of a w in l2 bowl
of well we can take W out right this is
a linear function all the way out so
we're going to get W and then 1 over N
some of epsilon T X T again X's are just
fixed Pinal and of course you notice
that this is a definition of the dual
norm and the dual norm to Euclidean norm
is Euclidean so this is nothing but the
expected value of 1 over n sum of
Epsilon
this is just the Euclidean norm now do
Jensen inequality the square and put a
square root
push the expectation into the square
root is the answer that's an upper bound
open the square the cross terms cancel
because of the expectation what remains
are the norms of the X's but they live
in a Union Bowl there is a square root
outside and there are n of them okay so
this is upper bounded by square root of
the expected sum of T from 1 to N 1 over
n norm of X G squared their bounds of
the norm by one a derivative the
expectation doesn't matter anymore
there's no expectation
founded by one over square root of man
so this is very simple calculation this
is a an obvious kind of set where it's
super easy to get the upper bound on the
width of the band that contains in
expectation the these two curves right
confused by the first inequality the
sense the the expectation on the left
hand side seems to not have anything to
do with the expectation of the right
that's it yes so let me I want to go
through the proof this expectation here
is over the XS and the Y's right over
the N copies of X's and Y's yes correct
so this side only depends on the random
draw of the XS it does not depend on the
random drove the Y's expectations for X
means I mean the little X so this X I'm
just saying with the respect to x1
through xn yes yes or 1 over N squared
thank you is that everyone comfortable
with this calculation yes not yet
because in that prediction there was no
covariance right no covariance so it's
slightly different object but very much
related to relate I will show that in
the second hour yes
there is something concentration I don't
know how many people are familiar which
says that a function of many random
variables is with high probability close
to its expectation right so one can
apply assuming boundedness one can apply
the concentration inequalities to say
that in fact we can we can with high
probability replace this expectation by
just the right amount or averages right
with high probability by using
concentration we can say is just the
Rademacher averages now
sorry yes we need to show that the
Rademacher is actually born [ __ ] for
yes so for the example that we have is
going to be the case right
maybe a different constant but was
enough for a government for it so as I
remember looking at this as a grad
student when I started and I remember
being buffle by the by this fact because
you know what this is saying is that you
know we don't know what the distribution
is but the Rademacher average is
something we can compute right these are
data dependent you have the data in
front of you this is another
optimization problem you just plug it in
right flip some coins and here we go so
the statement is that you can guarantee
closeness of one curve to another curve
which we actually we don't know buy
something that we know right it's kind
of strange right so so it says that you
can you can provide a certificate that
these two curves are similar even though
you don't know what the what the
underlying distribution is to which
you're trying to be close right it gives
you one sample yes so I think you're
referring to the fact that we need to do
concentration here as well which you can
that's right that's right that's right
is not through the sample buys so if you
do concentration on both sides then that
then further
every sample a bill for Hyper for mostly
with hyper our builder okay with hyper
builds here right for one minus delta
draws that's going to be the case
I'm moving quite a few things under the
rug
yes I mean you cannot get the simple
result maybe but but but all the kind of
so there are different ways then if the
function is not linear I think that's
what you're you're asking if the
function is not linear you cannot pull
this out and you cannot use the simple
analysis right okay right so any
ellipsis function will give you this up
to here
where would you use ensign its it's just
for this yeah just to get a quantitative
bound alright that's the only there are
many more refined bounds that one can
get that this is kind of the simplest
possible so I'm just hoping I'm just
trying to show that you know this
quantity rather marker averages it has a
long name it sounds scary was actually a
very simple concept and it's very much
related to something that maybe some of
you have seen called Gaussian widths and
if you've seen sparse recovery it's just
go you know it replace the Epsilon's
with the gaussian random variables again
iid it's roughly the same concept okay
yes that would lead to a supreme of a
Gaussian process rather than supreme of
Rademacher process you can go you know
so they're complicated relationships
maybe I have to log on you can come and
go from one to another in one direction
you go without any paying anything okay
so that's what we did so again what I
want to stress is that it's it's the the
performance of erm performance of best
fit to data is actually as good as one
over square root of n right so we
essentially prove that because these two
curves are within 1 over square root of
n when you minimize one objective which
is not the right objective you still
optimize the correct objective right is
this this clear so somehow right the the
because we phrase the problem in terms
of the expected objective but we can
only do the empirical objective we have
to somehow relate the two right that's
kind of the that's the idea ok so here
just again this is a very classical
results that is the co-learning expected
error of the empirical risk minimizer is
with hyper ability no more than the
expected risk the expected error of the
best model to up to this empirical
Rademacher complexity okay and I'm being
vague of course here and of course this
heavily relies on the fact that data are
iid
okay so empirical Rademacher is the
upper bound on the performance of
empirical risk minimization okay that's
that's what you should take out of this
just a few more details the proof that I
gave of course works for any pair of the
dual primal-dual norms right because the
only thing we used well if F is a ball
in some norm not necessarily Euclidean
norm then of course you pull out the W
and that's just the definition of the
dual norm and and so you get the star
here that's the dual more
right by definition of the dual normal
right and now now we can talk about the
different pairs L 1 L infinity L P and Q
with a conjugate PQ and in particular
you can talk about the the nuclear norm
Bowl I will okay next slide but for L 1
let's just see what the L 1 result is if
you take L 1 then the dual is L infinity
and for L infinity it's easier to see
I'm gonna be using the the less than or
equal with a squiggle meaning I'm I am
omit any constants right so this is just
the dependence on the parameters square
root of log dimension divided by n
that's the result that you would get if
you already know about experts probably
only if a couple of you this should
remind you of the experts bound
exponential weights bound and indeed
that's the connection that I would like
to get to the connection between the
empirical Rademacher averages and the
exponential weights or the weighted
majority algorithm so for the L 2 L 2
pair there was no dimension dependence
so you could be working in the infinite
dimensional hilbert space for L 1 L
infinity for instance dimension does
appear and and yes
so a VC is not a linear so for VC you
would say that this is not a linear
function it's a binary valued function
of X and then given the XS you're
looking at what are the different sign
patterns you can achieve using different
apps they don't apply they don't apply
each other right so the once you move
away from linear functions and talk
about binary valued functions you really
have to be thinking now about subsets of
the hypercube and the richness of those
subsets and what VC theory of the
buckling chain rank is theory gives you
is how rich those subsets are in terms
of something called the VC dimension
that's right right you break that's
right right right so so you can you can
you can bound Rademacher objects you
using covering numbers EE entropy
integral there's a whole machinery for
doing so this is the most the most basic
right and maybe I'm not gonna go into
this okay so let me talk about the
nuclear norm wall and and the dual is
spectral norm so that's hopefully clear
to people in that case the random occur
averages and that this is the movie
prediction problem right it's gonna be
the spectral norm of this random matrix
and there are you know we know a lot of
different ways of bounding this and and
just a very kind of quick the matrix
Bernstein result would tell you it's 1
over n because this is 1 over N V which
is the maximum of the spectral norm of
the inner product and outer product
right now let's just think about this
for the matrix example and by the way
there's again
Machinery of analyzing random matrix
spectral norms of random matrices in
terms of different parameters and this
is just one way of doing it in fact
there is a workshop up the hill at MSRI
on the subject so we can all go there
and ask them ok so for the matrix
completion example ok this is the X and
then it's clear that the V squared the
variance parameter is well when you take
these matrix times the matrix you're
just going to get something on the
diagonal all right and now you're adding
it up over the different examples and so
essentially it is the number maximum of
the number of times a column is repeated
and the maximum number of times the row
is repeated right so you could get
easily this result n CN n R is the
maximum frequency of movie or or person
occurrence right and so let's just get a
get a get a sense of X's are fixed here
but let's just hypothesize that X's are
random so let's go back to this setting
where X is are iid we observe the move
your user pairs completely at random
then you know how many do you expect for
each for each column one roughly and
divided by P right P is the is the
dimension of the matrix let's just
assume that p is equal to m m so there
are same number of users as the movies
then if you use the trace norm ball with
with this parameter then you get a
result of square root of R P over N and
that means that you get some non-trivial
performance as soon as the number of
examples that you see is a proportional
to just one side of the matrix right say
the number of users so that that's
already interesting because the you only
need to see not the
not the product of the dimensions but
just one dimension for the learning to
start kicking in however this heavy
heavily relies on uniform sampling right
which we don't believe is is true but I
just want to give you a sense that the
random awkward complexity already
captures the the data dependent
structure of the problem right well what
how many times a user movie pair was
picked and so forth and of course in the
worst case sampling all of them are on
the same user movie pair and so we get a
useless result which is P squared over N
and so the kind of learning only kicks
in when n is equal to of the word same
order is P squared which is not you
interesting ready when I get
generalization before you see all the
entries I want to say that there are
better results than this by Shamir and
Shelly Schwartz where they use the
boundedness of the entries to improve
this P squared but I will not talk about
that okay so now yes very very very
spiky yes yes yeah okay so what else
could we have done well we so far we
analyzed empirical risk minimization
well another thing we could have done is
treat the this minimization problem of
the expected objective the out-of-sample
objective as the stochastic optimization
problem and go through the data once and
do stochastic optimization right so this
is just a projector gradient descent
where each gradient nobility is the
gradient of the loss at a fresh data
point XT YT this is well known well
understood it is an unbiased estimate of
the gradient of the expected objective
as long as we never heat the data point
more than once right so if we start
going through the data more than once
there is no longer an unbiased estimate
right so conditionally on the on the
pass we should be having fresh data
right now this approach in fact has been
very influential in machine learning and
arguably led to the successes of deep
learning yes I get to say this and so
people in like shaileshwar it's a tall
road to this and influential paper on
the Pegasus the ANBU - in the machine
learning community has been advocating
the use of stochastic gradient descent
instead of the empirical minimization
objective right because this somehow
goes directly after the expected
objective right so yes yes absolutely
you still have that assumption is we
will be removing it if I get two so I
have three minutes left so let me say
that there seems to be two approaches
and one is called si that's another name
the stochastic approximation
the other one is si a sample average
approximation there is a nice paper by
números key and others on the two on
these two possibilities and and these
two different approaches if you think
that this is a new kind of idea let's go
back to the 1963 this is a quote from
Bob Nick's nature of statistical
learning theory inspired by Novikov
theorem so what is no because theorem if
you know perceptron this was the first
learning machine right at the beginning
of machine learning the Novikov theorem
says that if data are separable linearly
separable then there is only finite
number of adjustments by this gradient
descent procedure that will happen until
you find a hyperplane which is
consistent with the data
okay so inspired by Novikov theorem soup
can who is in a famous control
I guess theorist and Yzerman started
discussions on consistency of learning
process
in 1963 okay maybe I should switch to a
Russian accent in 1963 at the seminars
of the Moscow Institute of control
science to general inductive principles
that ensure consistency of learning
processes the laughter is not being
picked up by the unfortunate consistence
of learning processes were under
investigation
one is the principle of stochastic
approximation the other one in principle
a principle of empirical risk
minimization which are the two
approaches that I ought outline and by
the 1971 two types of theories have been
developed one is the general synthetic
theory of stochastic approximation and
and the other one is non asymptotic
theory by Vodnik German Incas for the
empirical risk minimization okay so this
is not definitely not a not a new idea
now I want to get at least kind of to
end this hour with an interesting puzzle
and I want to just go through the proof
of stochastic gradient descent right it
will be non asymptotic proof of course
this is a complex problem we know
exactly what the rate of convergence is
so what you do is you do stochastic
gradient descent with these unbiased
estimates and then you form the what's
called the pollak average of the
trajectory right so you do the gradient
descent then you average the iterates
and that's your W bar so there was a w
hat now it's a W bar W bar is the
average of the trajectory of the
stochastic gradient descent now what do
you do well you say the how well does
the W bar do with respect to any W star
that may be the optimal one well by
convexity you are bound by the average
of the suburb gemologist and then you
linearize the problem right just kind of
a standard way of doing it and and
because the gradients are unbiased you
know given the past you can write the
expected sub optimality of the you know
the performance of W bar as expected
average of these products right
this is like the first course you take
on convex optimization right but then
what you use is actually a completely
deterministic statement what is then
used is that this quantity inside of the
expectation is bounded by say 1 over
square root of N or something like that
and the rate of convergence and and this
proof is completely deterministic is
just the potential argument right you
look at the distance square to the
optimal point and and how that changes
and so what you actually do is what
what's called a regret you get that
deterministic regret statement that this
quantity is small right now the bound
that you're gonna get through this
analysis which I will put in and finish
here is gives you a 1 over square root
of n which is exactly the same as you
gotten from empirical risk minimization
so but of course it's an upper bound but
it tells you that the W bar has the same
performance guarantee as W hat and if I
were to write out the parameters that
are hidden here up to constants they
would be the same and so the question
that we'll discuss in the next hour is
this a coincidence or not and you'll see
that actually it's not a coincidence it
has a deeper connections between online
methods regret methods of this form and
uniform convergence result that you use
for the empirical risk minimization ok
so yes in half an hour we'll break any
questions
[Applause]
questions with or without Russian axes
this slide where you introduced rather
moderate complexity what's something
about the tightness yes so you can
provide a lower bound on the on the axis
loss in terms of Rademacher complexity
as well were the absolute loss function
that we use you can also provide a lower
bound on the expected supreme of the
deviation of empirical and expected in
terms of Rademacher complexity so the
Rademacher complexity and the uniform
deviations are related on both sides up
to a constant or multiplicative constant
for the learning for learning yes but
for uniform deviations it's it's not a
it's not a worst case statement they
control the calculation on offline
aw quit
okay then that's a half up and over
again
[Applause]